[Music]
Well, my name is John Peek. Um, I am a
developer advocate for GitHub. Uh, I've
been a software developer since the late
90s. Uh, and in developer advocacy for
about the last 10 years. So, it's been a
fun ride. Um AI is of course all the new
hotness. Um I want to talk to you all
today about really how you want to
approach learning AI inside your
organization. Right? A lot of us are at
that state where uh even some of us old
fogies are coming around and accepting
that there's a few LLMs that can do
things maybe better or at least faster
than us. Um, but there's also a lot of
confusion about how exactly we start
approaching this and and what kind of
motivations we can give our teams and
what kind of approaches to make sure
that it's efficient. Um, these are what
I'd say you're looking for, you know,
kind of best case scenarios, right? Um,
I like to focus on this third column
here, efficiency, because, you know, we
know that LM can pump out huge amounts
of code. So, what the question is, is
that actually getting you more feature
points? What we're seeing in best case
scenarios is up to uh one and a halfx in
how many feature points you can push out
in the same period of time. I'm seeing
averages more around 30% in most
companies. I'm seeing a lot of
improvement on the increase in
successful builds. Basically, that's
I've got an existing DevOps pipeline.
I've got existing tests and that sort of
thing. And when people are using AI,
those tests are clearing much more
often. Basically, we're hitting the
problems early on. I'm also seeing
general increases in developer happiness
which is really buoying to see. Also,
quick note, you'll see in the lower
right there's a URL gh.io/fair/unlock.
These slides are all available up there.
Please feel free to take pictures, but
I'll keep that URL up here and there so
you can always just find everything I'm
talking about. All right, so first off,
how do we ensure that we're actually
going to use AI efficiently? Um, a lot
of people's first approach is go out,
find some chat tool, throw some things
into it, get responses, copy and paste
it into your ID, right? Terribly slow,
hard to specify context, hard to iterate
in that model, also kind of exposed,
relatively insecure, right? So, step
one, kind of obvious, but let's just say
it, is make sure you're using an IDE
that has your AI incorporated directly.
hopefully one that's flexible enough to
use drag and drop options for pulling in
just the right context and helping it
narrow down so you're not just doing
everything and looking at all the files
all the time. I'll get into more
specifics about what we look for in an
ID. In this particular case, I'll be
spending a decent amount of time uh
using VS Code. That's my primary and
with GitHub Copilot because that's of
course my primary being an employee. Um
the other thing is that you want to make
sure that you're still ensuring model
choice. We may get to a point where
orchestrators are good enough to always
pick the right model at the right time.
We're not there yet. Um the advantage of
using a combined tool that has an all-in
subscription kind of thing is the
ability to go and pick the right model
at the right time. So I'm doing
something really fast. I just need quick
lowcost responses. I'm using a flash
model. I'm doing deep research and I'm
trying to explore a problem space before
I actually begin coding. I'm pulling out
a reasoning model. There's lots of
different cases where you'd use these
different things. All right. Now, when
you're ready to jump in, start with the
developer as the operator interactive
with the IDE. And the temptation here in
a lot of cases is to start Greenfield
because it's so cool and fun. Hey, I hop
into an AI. I say, "Hey, I want to build
uh Minecraft, except I want it to be
using the Doom engine, and I want it to
run on my dishwasher." Okay, cool. So, I
can do that, but it's not really
teaching me a lot about how to interact
with the AI, and it's also not what I'm
doing on a daily basis. Most of the
time, we're really working brownfield.
We're working on modifying an existing
application with a decent amount of code
already in it. And it's important for us
to get the patterns we need as we start
doing that work. So, I can jump into
something. I can say, hey, I want to do
something like I want to swap out uh my
OM from this one version to another or I
want to create tests for the things that
I've got already and I want to use this
data source to do it and that sort of
thing. And in that way, we start to
learn effectively the right pairings of
how we create those prompts and how we
shape the context that we're handing to
the model so it's doing the right work
at the right time. So really important
to get people invested in that direct
daily interaction and how to create and
shape those prompts and find the right
places to work. All right. Then you
might want to go back and you might want
to play around with green field
development now that you have those
practices and say okay how fast can I
create something new. A big step in
improvement with that and also with the
brownfield work is the existence now of
agent mode. Right? So, co-pilot agent
mode, others have this sort of thing,
too. And what you'll find with agent
mode, if you're working in a green field
context, you can use it to sort of
iterate on what the initial scoping
should be, get it to help you create
your prompt before you actually send the
full prompt. The way that I do this is
I'll open up a readme markdown or
something like that, and then I'll say
to the LM, hey, here's the kind of
application I want. What are the kinds
of specs I should create? It'll spit
something out, which is usually
nonsense. I'll refine it. I'll be like,
"No, I really want you to use these
technologies. I really want it to have
this particular file structure in the
trees. Here's an example of what an API
call should look like, etc." And when
I'm then at a point where I have a well
scoped document, something I'd feel good
handing to another engineer, then I can
hand that to the actual model to do my
build. In brownfield mode, the advantage
of agent mode is that it's going to be
able to take a large amount of context
and narrow it down so I'm not
overloading my prompt. So, I'm not
putting too much into it. That's going
to have the benefit of it working
correctly because it's narrowly scoped
enough that it'll actually fit inside
the call. It's going to have the second
benefit of having it not overrun.
Because if I tell it only focus on these
files on these folders, then it's not
going to try and do a whole bunch of
other stuff I don't want it to do,
right? So in that case, I'll do
something like I was talking about with
migrating the OM. I'll pull in just the
models folder. I'll pull in just the
backend Python Flask app or whatever it
is. I might pull in a few settings files
and then I'll tell it to go ahead and do
that task. The first thing I should see
my agent do in that case is it'll look
at those and it'll say, "Hey, I'm
further narrowing the context down.
Here's my plan for the kinds of actions
I'm going to take. And then it's going
to go and start building out each
separate section of the plan. I can
pause it. I can give it new instructions
and tell it continue from there if it's
going down the wrong path. Or this is
something we need to get comfortable
with as developers. If it's just made
500 changes, but I think it's working
completely the wrong way, immediately
just revert all of those and try again.
Right? There's not as much cost to
blowing away huge amounts of code as
there used to be. So I should be
comfortable with just erasing and
starting over. Obviously make sure
you're doing your commits in between at
each set point so you have a good git
history of things that actually worked.
Right? On that note, I'll talk about
copilot instructions in a minute, but
also when I'm doing my prompts, if I'm
just doing it that way, telling it to
keep a change log of what it's been
doing can be really, really handy. So I
just have a file where I can see all of
the edits that it made. Okay. Now, how
do we get into team mode? How do we
start taking these practices and sharing
them with our colleagues and making sure
we're working together well as a team?
Um, so first off, team practices and
docs don't go away, but they get better,
right? Yes, I'm always going to have my
standards. I'm always going to have
everything from like what's my committed
dependency file all the way to my
manuals and best practices and playbooks
of how we do things. But with the
addition of copilot instructions files,
I can now codify this. So when the AI is
working with me, it's also obeying those
best practices. In GitHub, the
instantiation of that is a file called
copilot-instructions.mmd
inside the GitHub folder in your repo.
Use that locally, but also commit that
file up into your repo. And then it's
part of your job as say a lead developer
or a team manager to make sure that
thing continues to be revised properly
so that when the team makes a decision,
hey, we're going to go with this linting
practice. We're going to go this way of
doing our model accessors, we're going
to have a different kind of pattern or
we're always going to check for the
specific problem. It's my job to make
sure that ends up in the copilot
instructions file. So as they're working
with AI, it's keeping all those same
best practices in mind.
Second, find a way to make your
institutional knowledge accessible to
the AI. In a limited sense, that can be
things like providing API
specifications,
existing patterns and ways of working to
the context as you work. If you're using
Copilot Enterprise, you have the
additional ability to create what are
called knowledge bases inside your
GitHub or these are basically
collections of repositories, each with
special names. So I might have one or
two or three repositories that are my
best examples of how to write an
accessible front end that are work well
with my blind operators. I might have
another which is our best practices for
using Python in certain specific machine
learning cases and yet another that
defines all of our internal APIs which
the LLM wouldn't know automatically
unless I was provided that context. I
can create these knowledge bases as
named items. And then when I as an
operator am working on a piece of code,
I can say add the knowledge base for
accessibility, add the knowledge base
for my internal finance APIs or whatever
it is. And now the LLM is informed as
I'm working and will obey those best
patterns.
Also, this is a subtle thing. It's a
human thing, but make it okay to be
wrong. Make it okay to ask questions and
admit your failures and bring them to
the team because we're all in learning
mode here. There's a lot of unknowns out
there. And if we try to be perfect and
always wait until we've got everything
right to push it out, we're not learning
and we're not helping the team grow. If
I find a flaw, I find a way that a
particular model is working wrong or I'm
having a problem I just can't solve in a
particular context, but I think someone
else might have on my team, throw it out
there. put it in your Slack, put it in
your team's chat, and then after you
have solved that problem, take that
knowledge that was generated, put it
into a centralized guide that everybody
can access, maybe in the repo, maybe in
a centralized team knowledge store, so
there's a history there of what problems
we found, what we solved, and other
developers can quickly reference those.
Lastly, just keep an eye on your team
and how they're using their AI tool use,
right? Uh in GitHub world, this surfaces
as the co-pilot metrics APIs, but you're
going to look for other things as well.
You know, whether you've got internal
tracking on usage, whether you're
looking at volume of code and the type
of code submitted, that sort of thing.
You want to make sure that people who
just don't happen to come across the
right tool, come across the right
pattern, or feeling a little bit
hesitant are not falling behind the rest
of your team. So, it's important to keep
track of that so you can help those
people who might not have had access.
All right. Now we can talk a little bit
about governance at a high level. Right?
These are further concerns you have
inside your organization. One, safety,
privacy, right? Make sure whatever tool
you're using is actually going through
proxies, going through sanitization,
etc. So what you're throwing out there
is not being reused in other contexts,
reused for training, get guarantees from
that provider. uh GitHub itself for
example uh will actually provide an
indemnicate indemnification clause in
its enterprises and also it's fully
optin for any tracking. So when you come
to us as an enterprise we're not
retraining based on your data or
anything like that. Every prediction is
getting trashed in its memory context.
Also make sure that you've got the
option to do general highle governance.
So for example, we can say at a
repository level always exclude these
items from the copilot context. Then
it's not accidentally leaking in
environment secrets and that sort of
thing as it's making predictions, right?
Um and then lastly, make sure that you
have orwide policy governance so that
every single maintainer of every
repository doesn't have a huge overhead
that you can say at an org level these
are the sets of policies we want in
terms of new edge features in terms of
which models people can access etc and
quickly get your wide governance under
control.
All right, coming back to how we work as
operators. The other thing I want to
remind folks is that while it's it's
really cool and obvious to generate new
actual production code inside our idees
using AIS, what we're going to find in
many cases is that you get good lift
there on the development side, but
there's a whole set of other use cases
you want to be considering that you're
actually going to get more lift early
on. Right? So, let's step through these.
In the planning phase, I can work
directly with an AI to figure out what
my largecale plan is for a feature or
for a new product. That includes
brainstorming with it about what
technologies are best, what are the
latest cool things, what kind of
infrastructure might I consider, etc. So
bring that in so you know you're going
down the right track early. On the
security side, we can use these tools to
quickly go through large existing code
bases and say, "What are you seeing for
potentially bad dependencies? What are
you seeing for bad patterns? Is there
something like, you know, cross-sight
scripting that exists inside this
product? Can we find those and remove
those quickly?" Testing. I find this to
be probably the the number two speed
gain that for a lot of us, we have a
huge backlog. And one of those things
that gets dropped is, do you have full
coverage? Do you have all of your test
cases? I can quickly and easily go in to
an existing codebase, say, hey, I want
you to generate tests for these modules.
Drag them in and I want you to use this,
pull in some JSON samples or use MCP to
connect to your database as data
examples for how to test that. And then
I want you to build me a bunch of unit
tests using these frameworks. And boom.
Usually in about 10% of the time it
would normally take me to build all
those tests, I've got at least a
functioning skeleton that I can update a
little bit. Deployment. Most of these
models are actually pretty good at
infrastructure. So when we get to that
point where our application is ready to
deploy, I can just say, hey, how do I
put this on whatever? Generate a GitHub
actions file, generate a Terraform file,
etc. And move those out. So now we're
moving even beyond the basic developer
scope. you're thinking about, I hope,
other roles in your organization that
you can bring in and give access to this
power who won't necessarily be thinking
on the day-to-day about the application,
but they can still benefit. And then I
find that the the number one speed gain
and actually additional role that I want
to include is documenters, right?
Because we all get to that point. Hey, I
built the code. It the the code is the
comment and I don't really care if the
end users know how to use it. That's
somebody else's problem.
just going in and spending that 15
minutes of hey document what this
application does produce a markdown file
give me a full API spec give me an
executive summary give me examples of
how I would actually interact with this
if I'm using a vision capable model give
me some graphs or if not mermaid charts
about what the actual workflows are
inside the application those are of huge
benefit possibly directly to your end
developers but at the very least the
people curating the documentation inside
your company, you're giving them a leg
up.
All right, I've got four minutes left,
so this will continue to be quick. Um,
let's talk about autonomous AI now. So,
everything I've talked about so far,
semi-autonomous, right? Even when I'm
working with an agent in the IDE, it's
doing a bunch of work, but it's pausing
every now and then, saying, "Am I
allowed to access the terminal to do
this? Does this plan look good?" etc.
But we're getting to the era now where
there are some things we can move into
fully autonomous autonomous modes,
right? A couple things to keep in mind
here. A, you're using this as a
timesaver. You want to use automation
where it makes sense, but you don't want
to drop it in everywhere blindly. And
you want to make sure there's always a
human in the loop in some way. As an
example, in GitHub world, this means
that when we're using autonomous agents,
they're always creating a new branch to
work on and its executions in a
protected environment. So that it's not
going to mess up your main branch of
code and it's not going to leak things
and destroy existing environments. It's
going to work in a box until I say it's
ready and I'm like that branch looks
good. Complete the PR and then we'll
actually merge it in. Don't skip that
step.
So a few ways we a few ways we can do
this. dead simplest audiogenerating PR
descriptions. For example, I've
completed a bunch of work. I want to
provide a good description to the people
downstream. I can now go in, I can open
a PR, I can just say, "Hey, co-pilot,
create a summary for this." It's going
to give me a high level and then like
key f file details. So, that's an easy
win that doesn't require any depth. But
then we get into more complicated stuff.
So, about six months ago, we added the
ability for co-pilot code review. I can
go into an existing pull request no
matter how it was created. I can assign
co-pilot set them as an assigne on that
pull request the same way that I would
set a human as an assigne and co-pilot
asynchronously is going to come along
take a look at that pull request and
it's going to start generating comments
and code suggestions. Now these won't be
automatically injected. They'll show up
and this is our major philosophy the
same way anything a human would do.
We're still using that same skeleton of
all the existing GitHub methodology. So
if another human comes along and they
make a code suggestion on your PR, it
shows up as something you can accept or
reject. Same thing with Copilot. It'll
say, "Hey, I don't think that this
particular function is as efficient as
it could be. Here's a suggested rewrite.
Do you want to accept it?" And you get
as an operator the choice of whether or
not to do it. But the benefit is it can
do all of that while you're working on
something else and you just come back
half an hour later and look at all its
comments. kind of the same way you it
work asynchronously with another
developer. Um the other I would point
you to is this new ability to say all
right assign an issue directly to
co-pilot. Now this sounds dangerous but
again everything happens in isolation on
its own branch and you want to be
judicious. You know there's only so many
giant highcoped issues that you'd
necessarily want to assign to something
totally anonymous autonomous. Uh but
when you are doing something like hey
there's not enough documentation hey I
need to add tests for this hey I want to
add this one function that does XYZ
writing a well-shaped issue the same way
you would write a well-shaped prompt say
focus on these do these exact things
these should be the outcomes this should
be the test generated and then take that
issue and try assigning it to copilot
copilot will take that it'll create a
new branch create a new PR work
autonomously ly for a while, provide you
with what it thinks is a completed PR
that's ready to go and then you get to
take a look at that and say either this
was terrible just destroy the whole PR
and try again I'll refine my issue and
reassign it or uh you did one little
thing wrong put a comment into that PR
copilot will come back make some more
modifications on the branch and present
you with that set of changes or it's
good to go in which case boom run my
standard CI/CD pipeline make sure
everything's could merge it on in.
All right, and I'm just about at time,
so I'll leave you with this one last
thing, which is MCP servers. Right, so
MCP is now available in two places. One
is in VS Code itself, where you can go
in and you can add an MCP. Go to that
URL,
github.com/modelcontextprotocol/servers,
and pick ones that are applicable to
your workflow, the technologies you're
using, the kinds of things you want to
do. An obvious one I'd point out is
GitHub itself has an MCP server. So now
you can say things to your agent after
you've added it. Like, hey, uh, okay, I
love all the work you just did. Uh, put
it on a new branch. Uh, go ahead and
commit it with a sensible commit. Uh,
and then create a new PR for it and
assign so and so to approve that PR and
the agent will just do it for you. You
don't have to flip context and come back
out to GitHub and work through the web
API. Um, the other thing is that this is
also now available for those of you
using copilot enterprise to use with the
other agentic interactions I just talked
about. So you can actually configure
your MCP at the repository level and
then when you're doing something like
assigning copilot to an issue, it can
take advantage of those MCP connections
right there and it can reach out to
other systems as it's trying to
accomplish its work. I'll leave you with
this last slide which is again there on
that URL gh.iofair.unlock
just a bunch of convenience links for
training cheat sheets that sort of
thing. Thanks very much for your time
and I'll be out in the hallway if anyone
wants to chat more later.
[Music]